sixteen-year-old malala yousafzai was
the center of attention at the european
parliament and the teenage campaigner
used her latest appearance in the
spotlight to push her cause the fight
against the oppression of children and
the struggle for more education
and these children
they do not want
an iphone an xbox a playstation or
chocolates
they just want
a book
and a pen thank you so much
the speech left a deep impression on
parliament
anyone who has just heard the girl and
listened to her speech can only be
deeply moved
i think we've seen a girl today who was
more likely to defeat the fanaticism of
the taliban than the drones are
motivated
i feel motivated and inspired by this
fearless young woman to support her
wherever i have the possibility to have
political influence she's my hero
malala received the eu's sakurao prize
to honour her fight against the
oppression of women and girls by the
taliban in pakistan's smart valley
a year ago that engagement nearly cost
her her life
a taliban gunman shot her in the head on
a school bus
but since that attack she's taken on the
extremists
by spreading the message that knowledge
is the best response